Michael had been in the business for over 35 years, and he never had a customer like this one. Michael designs and sells tombstones. And this customer, who we're not going to name for reasons that will become clear the further into the story I get-- we'll just call him Mr. X-- Mr. X is what they call in the funeral business a pre-needs customer. Pre-needs is basically a polite funeral business way to say he wasn't dead. He was buying a plot and a tombstone before he needed them.
迈克尔从事这个行业已经超过35年了，他从来没见过这样的客户。迈克尔负责设计和销售墓碑。而这位客户——出于显而易见的原因，我们不便透露其姓名，姑且称他为X先生——X先生在殡葬业被称为“预需”客户。预需基本上是殡葬业一种委婉的说法，意指他还没死。他在需要之前就在购买墓地和墓碑。
You know, he explained that this was for himself, and he said he had some special requests that he wanted on the memorial. So I obviously asked what they were, and we started going through it. He wanted his picture on there. He also wanted to know if he could put his son's names on and their pictures, and he would also like to put their dates of death.
你知道，他解释说这是为他自己准备的，他还说他在纪念碑上有一些特殊要求。所以我显然问了那些要求是什么，我们就开始逐一过了一遍。他想把他的照片放上去。他还想知道是否可以放上他儿子的名字和照片，而且他还想放上他们的死亡日期。
And at that point, I say, "oh, I'm very sorry for your loss." And that's when he says, "no, they're not dead." And I was slightly speechless for a moment because I'm trying to figure out what's go on. Is he trying to tell me that he's going to kill them? Or is it-- what's happening? You know.
就在那一刻，我说：“哦，我很遗憾听到这个消息。”接着他说：“不，他们还没死。”我有一瞬间说不出话来，因为我在试图弄清楚发生了什么。他是想告诉我他要杀了他们吗？还是说——发生了什么？你知道的。
And so we proceeded slightly further in the conversation, and he basically takes out a sheet of paper and hands it to me. And I start reading it, and he said, "this is what I want on the monument."
于是我们继续往下谈，他基本上拿出一张纸递给我。我开始读它，他说：“这就是我想要刻在纪念碑上的内容。”
And what did it say?
上面写了什么？
Well, I wish I had it and saved it. It was really very blunt, to the effect that, "my two sons stole money from me." And it kind of broke his heart. In his eyes, they were not alive any longer.
嗯，我真希望我当时留存了它。内容非常直白，大意是：“我的两个儿子偷了我的钱。”这让他心碎了。在他眼中，他们已经不再活着了。
They were dead to him.
对由于某种原因，他们在他心中已经死了。
They're dead to him because of something they did to him.
他们在他心中死了，因为他们对他所做的事情。
When I first read it, it didn't even click. And then I read it again, and I looked at him and said, "are you serious?" And he said, "yes." I said, "OK." I said, "it's pretty strong." And he said, "that's what I want."
当我第一次读到它时，我甚至没反应过来。然后我又读了一遍，我看着他说：“你是认真的吗？”他说：“是的。”我说：“好的。”我说：“这非常强烈。”他说：“这就是我想要的。”
And the cemetery wouldn't allow him to put it on there in that way. And you need to, you know, kind of soften it up a little bit.
而墓地管理方不允许他以那种方式刻上去。你需要，你知道，稍微温和一点。
And I should say now, this monument is actually standing. The guy still is alive. The monument is standing in a cemetery right now, and it has his picture-- kind of a big picture of him at the top, and his name, and date of birth, and then blank for the date of death-- and then underneath it there are pictures of two of his sons. Then it says, "in memory of." And it says each of their names and the date of death. And I guess those are the dates when they broke his heart and became dead to him.
我现在应该说，这座纪念碑实际上已经立好了。那个人还活着。这座纪念碑现在就立在墓地里，上面有他的照片——顶部有一张他比较大的照片，还有他的名字、出生日期，死亡日期那一栏是空白的——然后在下方有他两个儿子的照片。接着上面写着“纪念”。后面是他们每个人的名字和死亡日期。我想那些就是他们伤透他的心并在他心中死去的那一天。
Exactly.
没错。
And then underneath-- let me just ask you to read the text of what it says underneath. And leave out their names.
然后下方——我能请你读一下下方写的文字吗？跳过他们的名字。
OK. It says, "I'll never forget"-- and someone's name-- "and"-- someone's name. "Even in death, these two people put an everlasting mark on my heart. Money will come between family no matter how close you are. Even in death, I still feel the pain."
好的。上面写着：“我永远不会忘记”——某人的名字——“和”——某人的名字。“即使在死后，这两个人也在我的心中留下了永恒的印记。无论家人多么亲密，金钱总会横亘在你们之间。即使在死后，我仍能感到痛苦。”
I called this guy. I talked to him. In fact, I've talked to him a couple times, and he didn't want to come on the radio or anything. And he explained that in his mind, this was the perfect plan. Because basically, he could finally get the last word.
我给这个人打了电话。我和他谈过。事实上，我和他谈过几次，但他不想上广播什么的。他解释说，在他看来，这是一个完美的计划。因为基本上，他终于可以获得最终的话语权了。
Yeah, and it's cut in stone. That's a saying around here. It's permanent. It's there forever, for eternity.
是的，而且这是刻在石头上的。这是我们这里的一句俗语。它是永久的。它将永远存在，直到永恒。
Now, when I talked to Mr. X about all this, he told me that he carries around photos of the monument, and he shows those photos to people. He likes seeing their reactions. He says that he visits the monument every five or six weeks, polishes it up. He has a fantasy of his sons coming to his funeral and seeing the monument for the first time. He pictures the looks on their faces.
现在，当我与X先生谈论所有这些时，他告诉我他随身带着纪念碑的照片，并向人们展示这些照片。他喜欢看到他们的反应。他说他每五六周就会去参观一次纪念碑，把它擦拭干净。他幻想着他的儿子们参加他的葬礼并第一次看到这座纪念碑。他在脑海中勾勒他们脸上的表情。
But the problem with this plan-- and Mr. X is the very first person to admit this-- the problem with this plan is, who wants to wait until they're dead to get the satisfaction? You know? On the other hand, if they find out now, while he's alive, then they might get mad, they might argue. And that would defeat the whole point of the whole thing. He wouldn't get the last word. And Michael sees another problem with Mr. X's plan.
但这个计划的问题在于——而且X先生是第一个承认这一点的人——这个计划的问题是，谁想等到死了才得到满足感？你知道吗？另一方面，如果他们现在在他活着的时候发现了，那么他们可能会生气，他们可能会争吵。而这会破坏整件事情的目的。他就得不到最终的话语权了。迈克尔看出了X先生计划的另一个问题。
Maybe they're just going to look at it and go, "oh, he's crazy. Who cares?" You know what I mean?
也许他们只会看一眼，然后说：“哦，他疯了。谁在乎呢？”你明白我的意思吗？
Oh, wouldn't that be horrible for him?
哦，那对他来说不是很糟糕吗？
Yeah. And then they'd just walk away.
是的。然后他们就会直接走开。
That would be the worst case scenario, that they would see it and just shrug.
那将是最坏的情况，他们会看到它然后只是耸耸肩。
And it wouldn't surprise me if they spotted the monument-- I'm almost thinking that if the sons saw that, they would probably try to remove their photographs, at least, which they could do. They could break them or remove them. Because I think he was even concerned about that.
如果他们发现了纪念碑，我一点也不会感到惊讶——我甚至在想，如果儿子们看到了，他们很可能会尝试移除他们的照片，至少他们可以这样做。他们可以破坏或拆除它们。因为我认为他甚至对此感到担忧。
Oh, he was?
哦，他是吗？
Yeah. I think he might have been going to leave some money somehow set up in a trust or something to take care of replacing them or something like that if something happened to them.
是的。我想他可能打算以某种方式设立信托基金来处理更换它们的事情，或者如果它们出了什么事，就做点类似的事。
You know, in the end, this is the problem with Mr. X's plan: all of eternity is stretching in front of Mr. X, and in that time, somebody can deface the tombstone, or a great, great, great, great, great, great grandson can decide that it is embarrassing, this tombstone, and have it removed.
你知道，归根结底，这就是X先生计划的问题所在：永恒在X先生面前延伸，在那段时间里，有人可能会损毁墓碑，或者他的玄孙可能会认为这座墓碑令人尴尬，并将其拆除。
Well, today on our show, we have stories of people who put together what they think are brilliant plans, and then all sorts of things that they didn't really account for finally get to them. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
好了，今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲一些人制定了他们认为很棒的计划，然后他们没有真正考虑到的各种各样的事情最终还是找到了他们的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our show today, My Brilliant Plan, in two acts. Act One, Mr. Adam's Neighborhood. That act is a simple story involving a money-saving, information-getting, life-embracing plan that just had one thing, one little thing going against it, and that is where it was happening. Act Two, Tragedy Minus Time Equals Happily Ever After. In that act, an 11-year-old child makes up a plan, a completely unlikely kid's plan, the kind of plan that no adult would ever think could work. And then the kid sticks with that plan into his 20s, into his 30s, into his 40s, into his 50s. He sticks with this plan for so long that somehow this fantastically unreasonable plan becomes, decades later, somehow suddenly rather reasonable. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目《我的天才计划》，分为两幕。第一幕，亚当先生的邻里。那一幕是一个简单的故事，涉及一个省钱的、获取信息的、拥抱生活的计划，只是有一件事，一件小事对它不利，那就是它发生的地方。第二幕，悲剧减去时间等于从此幸福快乐。在那一幕中，一个11岁的孩子编造了一个计划，一个完全不可能的孩子气计划，那种任何成年人都不会认为可行的计划。然后这个孩子把这个计划坚持到了他的20多岁、30多岁、40多岁、50多岁。他坚持这个计划太久了，以至于不知何故，几十年后，这个极其不合理的计划突然变得相当合理了。请继续收听。
Act One, Mr. Adam's Neighborhood. This story takes place in Iraq. But it's not a big story. Nobody is dying in the story. Democracy doesn't hang in the balance in this story. But it illustrates some things about what it's like to be an American trying to get anything at all done in Iraq, even something simple and ordinary, like rent a house, and how naive a person can be, how much you can stumble even doing that.
第一幕，亚当先生的邻里。这个故事发生在伊拉克。但这不是一个大故事。故事里没有人死去。在这个故事中民主并没有命悬一线。但它说明了一些作为美国人试图在伊拉克完成任何事情是什么感觉，即使是像租房子这样简单平凡的事情，以及一个人可以有多天真，甚至在做这件事时可以有多少踉跄。
One of our regular contributors here at This American Life, Adam Davidson, moved to Baghdad back in 2003. This wasn't long after the US invasion. He was a reporter for the public radio show Marketplace. He was reporting there, by the way, especially on corruption in the American reconstruction projects. Eventually, he won the Daniel Schorr Journalism Prize, and was a finalist for the duPont-Columbia Award.
我们《美国生活》的常驻撰稿人之一亚当·戴维森在2003年搬到了巴格达。那是在美国入侵后不久。他是公共广播节目《市场》的记者。顺便提一下，他在那里报道，特别是关于美国重建项目中的腐败问题。最终，他获得了丹尼尔·肖尔新闻奖，并入围了杜邦-哥伦比亚奖。
But back when he first arrived in Baghdad, he had to figure out where to live. And he noticed that not only was it expensive to live in the big hotels where Western journalists stayed, those hotels were just starting to get bombed. So he came up with a plan-- it seemed like a very clever plan at the time-- to rent a house. He was going to rent a house. He was going to get a bunch of roommates to share the costs, save some dough. And they were going to live in a regular neighborhood. Not the green zone, which is the protected zone that Americans control. This was out in the city, in a regular, unprotected neighborhood.
但在他刚到巴格达时，他不得不弄清楚住在哪里。他注意到西方记者居住的大酒店不仅昂贵，而且那些酒店刚开始遭到轰炸。于是他想出了一个计划——当时看起来是个非常聪明的计划——租一栋房子。他打算租一栋房子。他打算找几个室友来分担费用，省点钱。他们将住在普通的街区里。不是绿区，那是美国人控制的保护区。这是在城市外，一个普通的、不受保护的街区。
One of our show's producers, Nancy Updike, was in Iraq reporting for a month back then, and she stayed at that house, and recently talked with Adam about the saga of what came to pass there. When this story first ran on our show a year ago, it was before the surge and other changes in Iraq had started to curtail the amount of violence in Baghdad. But of course, it's still quite a violent place.
我们节目的制片人之一南希·厄普代克当时在伊拉克报道了一个月，她就住在那个房子里，最近和亚当谈论了那里发生的事情的传奇。当这个故事一年前首次在我们的节目中播出时，是在伊拉克的增兵和其他变化开始减少巴格达的暴力事件之前。但当然，那里仍然是一个相当暴力的地方。
It does seem absolutely crazy now. I mean, the idea of going out and renting a house in Baghdad today, it would be instant suicide. But back then, in 2003, it was such a different place. I had friends who would go jogging in this track at Baghdad University. I'd go shopping every day. And I felt totally safe. I would wander-- I can remember there would be these angry protests-- and I would wander into these protests of hundreds of screaming young men and interview them, and felt no fear. I don't think I was irresponsible. I had an awareness things could get out of control.
现在看来确实完全疯了。我的意思是，今天去巴格达租房子的想法，那简直就是自杀。但在那时，2003年，那是一个完全不同的地方。我有一些朋友会在巴格达大学的跑道上慢跑。我每天都去购物。我感到非常安全。我会游荡——我记得会有这些愤怒的抗议——我会游荡进数百名尖叫的年轻人的抗议活动中采访他们，没有感到任何恐惧。我不认为我不负责任。我意识到事情可能会失控。
But having a house seemed like the smart move. It seemed like the clever, safe move, because we'd be off in the city somewhere, invisible. It seemed so much smarter than being in one of these big compounds with lots and lots of foreigners that was like easy pickings for any insurgent.
但拥有一栋房子似乎是明智之举。这似乎是聪明、安全的举动，因为我们会身处城市的某个地方，隐形。这看起来比待在这些到处都是外国人的大院子里要聪明得多，那对任何叛乱分子来说就像是容易下手的目标。
And just lay out the finances. How much were you paying in rent? And what were the costs of this place?
那么请讲一下财务状况。你付多少租金？这个房子的成本是多少？
Well, here's how I figured it. It was $14,000 every three months' rent. I knew I needed a staff, a couple security guards and a cleaning lady. So let's say with them it's $5,000 a month. We had five or six bedrooms. I had one British journalist who was committed to a little over $2,000 a month. Marketplace was going to throw $1,000 a month in, so I really only needed $2,000 a month.
嗯，我是这么计算的。每三个月的租金是14,000美元。我知道我需要工作人员，几个保安和一名清洁女工。所以假设加上他们是每月5,000美元。我们有五六间卧室。我有一位英国记者承诺每月支付2,000多美元。市场栏目组打算每月投入1,000美元，所以我实际上只需要每月2,000美元。
Marketplace was your employer at the time.
市场栏目组是你当时的老板。
My employer at the time was going to give me $1,000 a month, Marketplace. So all I needed was to make $2,000 a month and I had three bedrooms.
我当时的雇主，市场栏目组，打算每月给我1,000美元。所以我所要做的就是每月赚2,000美元，我就有三间卧室。
It seemed like a no-brainer.
这看起来很简单。
It seemed like a no-brainer. You know, I started asking myself, "is it ethical for me to actually make money?" You know, "I'll probably rent each of those bedrooms out for over $1,000 a month. So at the very least, maybe I won't pay anything, and maybe I'll even make money."
这看起来很简单。你知道，我开始问自己，“我真的赚钱合乎道德吗？”你知道，“我可能会以每月超过1,000美元的价格出租其中的每一间卧室。所以至少，也许我不用付任何钱，甚至可能还会赚钱。”
Given everything that happened in later months, I just can't help but laugh at this moment in time when you were feeling guilty at how you were going to be taking advantage of other people by making a profit, which you obviously never were able to do.
鉴于后来几个月发生的一切，我无法不嘲笑你在那种时刻感到内疚，觉得你会通过获利来利用其他人，而你显然从来没能做到这一点。
No, I'm still paying off. I'm actually still-- I think I've got my debts, because of the house, down to about $4,000 now.
不，我还在还债。我实际上仍然——我想我的债务，因为那栋房子，现在降到了大约4,000美元。
Are you kidding? You still have $4,000 worth of debt from this house?
你在开玩笑吗？你还有4,000美元的房子债务？
Yeah, which I owe my mom because she lent me the money. But yeah, I still owe $4,000 from the house, and it's-- you know, I left it two and a half years ago.
是的，我欠我妈妈的，因为她借给了我钱。但是的，我还欠着4,000美元的房子债务，而且——你知道，我两年前搬离了那里。
How much have you paid off between when you left and now?
你搬走到现在还了多少？
I came back, like, $22,000 in debt.
我回来时，背负着大约22,000美元的债务。
Oh my god, Adam.
天哪，亚当。
Yeah. Which means my entire salary, plus Marketplace's expenses, plus $22,000 went into that place.
是的。这意味着我的全部工资，加上市场栏目组的开支，加上22,000美元都进了那个地方。
But let's go back before the debt, before everything that would happen later. Just talk about what it was like in the beginning, because in the beginning, the house did seem to work like you wanted it to.
但让我们回到债务之前，回到后来发生一切之前。就谈谈一开始是什么感觉吧，因为一开始，房子似乎确实像你想要的那样运作。
Yeah, I mean, in the very beginning everything seemed to be working pretty well.
是的，我的意思是，在最开始一切似乎都进行得相当顺利。
Working pretty well how? How would a typical day go?
进行得相当顺利是指什么？典型的一天是怎么过的？
You know, a typical morning is everyone goes out and reports their story. But in the evenings, everyone comes back and we would just have these lovely dinner parties. We would have friends over for dinner from the hotels. People would come over, or from the other newspaper, radio, or TV houses would come over. And the wine tended to be pretty awful, but the beer was good, and you could get hard liquor. And it was just really fun. And word would get out.
你知道，典型的一天早上每个人都出去报道他们的故事。但在晚上，每个人回来，我们就会举办这些可爱的晚宴。我们会邀请酒店的朋友来吃晚饭。人们会过来，或者来自其他报纸、广播或电视房子的人会过来。葡萄酒通常很糟糕，但啤酒很好，你可以弄到烈酒。而且真的很有趣。消息传开了。
One of the things I really loved about the house is the entire time I was in the house, the US was occupying Iraq. And you would go to these kind of formal settings, and you'd meet these US occupying officials, and they were so tight-lipped, so on-message, so incapable of communicating. And so the ones I liked I'd invite over to the house. I mean, I genuinely liked them, but also we'd get them a little drunk on wine. We'd tell them, hey, tonight everything's off the record. And we'd get real information.
关于这栋房子，我非常喜欢的一点是，我在房子里的整个期间，美国都在占领伊拉克。你会去这些正式场合，遇到这些美国占领官员，他们非常口风紧，非常只说官话，非常缺乏沟通能力。所以我喜欢的那些我会邀请他们到家里来。我的意思是，我是真心喜欢他们，而且我们也让他们喝了点葡萄酒。我们会告诉他们，嘿，今晚的一切都不予报道。我们就能得到真实的信息。
I mean, that was how I found out that, even within the CPA, even within the US occupational forces, all these people running Iraq, people realized this is a disaster. We were getting this public message from the White House and from the folks in Iraq that everything's going really well, we just don't know it. But we'd get these people over to our house, they'd have some wine, and they'd be like, "oh, it's so much worse than you know."
我的意思是，这就是我发现的方式，即使在CPA内部，即使在美国占领军内部，管理伊拉克的所有这些人，人们也意识到这是一场灾难。我们从白宫和伊拉克的人那里得到了这种公共信息，说一切都进行得非常顺利，只是我们不知道。但我们会把这些人请到家里，他们喝点葡萄酒，他们就会说，“哦，情况比你知道的要糟得多。”
And I liked hanging out the Iraqi staff, the guards and drivers. It was really fun. One of the guards was a sheik of a tribe, and I would sit with him and learn tribal law, and how do you resolve conflicts. One of our nighttime guards had a small business. He had a little stationery shop, and I would learn from him about these new taxes that Shiite militias were charging, and the business people who were in favor of the resistance against the Americans.
我喜欢和伊拉克员工、保安和司机在一起。真的很有趣。其中一名保安是一个部落的谢赫，我会和他坐在一起，学习部落法，以及如何解决冲突。我们的一名夜间保安有一个小生意。他有一个小文具店，我会从他那里了解什叶派民兵征收的新税，以及支持反美抵抗运动的商人们。
But also, I didn't like all of our staff, but I liked a lot of our staff. I went to many of their houses for dinner, which is a big deal Iraq to have a guest for dinner.
但也有些员工我不喜欢，但我喜欢我们很多员工。我去了他们很多人的家吃晚饭，在伊拉克有客人来家里吃饭是一件大事。
And all the time you were also learning Arab.
而且你一直也在学习阿拉伯语。
And I was learning Iraqi Arabic. But it wasn't even just to learn. It was just fun. You know, we would-- I don't know. They were just funny, cool guys. I liked a lot of them.
我在学习伊拉克阿拉伯语。但这甚至不仅仅是为了学习。这只是很有趣。你知道，我们会——我不知道。他们只是有趣、酷的家伙。我喜欢他们很多人。
And then, at some point, things started to go wrong. What first just started to kind of break down?
然后，在某个时候，事情开始出问题了。首先开始崩溃的是什么？
The truth is, things were going wrong from the very beginning. It was just a very slow process of realizing it. I mean, one of the things, I had a translator who I was very close to and a driver I was very close to. And we are all good friends, so I get the house and before we even move in I say, "hey, I need security staff." So my driver and translator say, "oh, have we got the guys for you."
事实是，事情从一开始就出问题了。这只是一个意识到这一点的缓慢过程。我的意思是，其中一件事，我有一个非常亲近的翻译和一个非常亲近的司机。我们都是好朋友，所以我得到房子后，在我们搬进去之前我就说，“嘿，我需要保安人员。”所以我的司机和翻译说，“哦，我们有合适的人选推荐给你。”
"He just happens to he related to us."
“他刚好是我们的亲戚。”
Yeah. So my driver-- let's call him Faras-- so Faras, my driver, says, "listen, my wife's father, you know, he was in the army. This is a guy who's a trained security man. He is hardcore." I hire him sight unseen. I say, "sure. He sounds perfect." [? Abu Rasheed ?] is going to be my nighttime guard. [? Abu Rasheed ?] shows up. He's this short, very overweight, late 50s guy. Walks in, first question: "where do I sleep?"
是的。所以我的司机——我们称他为法拉斯——所以法拉斯，我的司机，说，“听着，我妻子的父亲，你知道，他在军队待过。这是一个受过训练的保安人员。他非常强硬。”我没面试就雇用了他。我说，“当然。他听起来很完美。”阿布·拉希德将是我的夜间保安。阿布·拉希德出现了。他是一个矮个子、非常超重、50多岁的人。走进来，第一个问题：“我睡哪儿？”
That is not a promising start for the nighttime security guard.
这对夜间保安来说不是一个好的开始。
And he didn't seem to know how to use a gun, and I didn't have the guts to fire him. So he stayed on throughout.
而且他似乎不知道怎么用枪，而我没有勇气解雇他。所以他一直留着。
Then my translator proposed his uncle, first to be a driver for some of the people who lived in the house. But on the first day he went out with one of my friends, it turned out he spoke no English whatsoever and didn't know Baghdad at all because he was from Najaf. He actually was kind of a big, tough-looking guy, kind of growly. He seemed to know how to use a gun. But then I learned the reason he had moved to Baghdad from Najaf was his father was the leader of the Baath party in Najaf, and Najaf is the capital of the Shiite world. It is the most anti-Baathist part of Iraq. At the time, there were death squads going around killing former Baathists, and so--
然后我的翻译推荐了他的叔叔，最初是给住在这个房子里的一些人当司机。但在他和我的一位朋友出去的第一天，结果发现他根本不会说英语，而且完全不认识巴格达，因为他来自纳杰夫。他实际上是一个看起来又大又强硬的家伙，有点粗鲁。他似乎知道怎么用枪。但后来我了解到他从纳杰夫搬到巴格达的原因是他父亲是纳杰夫复兴党的领导人，而纳杰夫是什叶派世界的中心。它是伊拉克最反复兴党的部分。当时，有死亡小队到处杀害前复兴党人，所以——
He needed to get out of town.
他需要离开那个城镇。
He needed to get out of town, and he came to our house to be our guard. Because, when you're an American in Baghdad, it always helps to also have a former Baathist Shiite guy in your house who is on the run from death squads.
他需要离开那个城镇，他来到我们的房子当我们的保安。因为，当你是一个在巴格达的美国人时，如果你房子里有一个正在躲避死亡小队的什叶派前复兴党人，总是会有帮助的。
Guarding your house.
保护你的房子。
Guarding your house. So very quickly there was a lot of competition. The driver wanted more of his relatives and fewer of the translator's relatives, and vice versa.
保护你的房子。所以很快就有很多竞争。司机想要更多的亲戚，而翻译想要更少的翻译的亲戚，反之亦然。
Because we were the one place that was filled with a constantly shifting array of freelancers-- people who needed drivers and translators-- we ended up being a gathering point for all these different Iraqi drivers and translators for hire. And someone would come and work with a guest for a few weeks, and then they'd just sort of hang out and wait for the next guest. And it took me way too long to realize that these guys were form-- the different drivers and translators, I mean, there could be days where there was a dozen or more-- they were forming different alliances. They tended to mostly be Shiite because they all knew each other. There was a few Sunnis, but mostly Shiite. But they'd be from different neighborhoods, from different tribes. They'd have different backgrounds. So there would be factions fighting each other, and there was just a lot of manipulation, a lot of anger.
因为我们是一个充满了不断变化的自由职业者的地方——那些需要司机和翻译的人——我们最终成了所有这些需要雇佣的伊拉克司机和翻译的聚集点。有人会和客人一起工作几周，然后他们就只是待在那儿等待下一位客人。我花了太长时间才意识到这些家伙是前——不同的司机和翻译，我的意思是，可能有一天会有十几个或更多——他们正在形成不同的联盟。他们大多是什叶派，因为他们都认识。有几个逊尼派，但大多是什叶派。但他们来自不同的街区，来自不同的部落。他们有不同的背景。所以会有派系互相争斗，有很多操纵，有很多愤怒。
The hardest thing: I really wanted to fire a few people. I felt they weren't doing their job. And I never could. I got to know them all so well. I knew how desperate they were, how poor they were, how much they needed the money. The average government ministry employee was making $20 a month. And every problem that came up I dealt with by throwing money at it. So I didn't like the guards, but I didn't fire them or cut their pay. I hired additional guards. The guests weren't buying enough food, I would pay more money for more food.
最困难的事情：我真的很想解雇几个人。我觉得他们没做好工作。但我从来没能这样做。我太了解他们所有人了。我知道他们有多绝望，多贫穷，他们有多需要钱。普通政府部门员工月薪20美元。我处理出现的每一个问题的方法都是砸钱。所以我不喜欢保安，但我没有解雇他们或减薪。我雇了额外的保安。客人买的食物不够，我会花更多的钱买更多的食物。
I remember one day-- the house came with this kind of old, cranky generator that always had a lot of problems. That was another big money drain. We were constantly hiring people to come fix it. So it dies, 4:45 PM, before the big Eid, which is a week-long holiday. Nothing's open. No stores are open. Everything's closed. And we drive like crazy. There's one store open. They have one generator. And the guy, the salesmen or the owner immediately knows.
我记得有一天——房子自带了一个那种又旧又暴躁的发电机，总是出很多问题。那是另一个巨大的金钱消耗。我们不断地雇人来修它。结果它死机了，下午4:45，在大开斋节前，这是一个为期一周的假期。什么都不开门。没有商店开门。一切都关了。我们疯狂地开车。有一家店开着。他们有一台发电机。那个家伙，销售员或老板立刻就知道了。
He knows exactly what's going on.
他确切地知道发生了什么。
He knows I need this generator.
他知道我需要这台发电机。
He's got you.
他吃定你了。
He charged me like $5,500, way more than I want to spend, but I just shelled the money out immediately. Then we had to hire a guy with a truck to carry the thing with one of these giant cranes, and then to take away the old generator, and to install the new generator. And then we had to hire a team of electricians to plug it in. I don't even remember, it was several hundred dollars.
他向我收取了大约5,500美元，比我想要花的钱多得多，但我还是立刻把钱掏出来了。然后我们不得不雇一个带卡车的人用其中一台巨大的起重机运送它，然后运走旧的发电机，安装新发电机。然后我们不得不雇一个电工团队来接线。我甚至不记得了，那是几百美元。
We had two refrigerators when we started. They both broke. The microwave broke. So I had to buy new fridges. I had to buy new microwaves.
我们刚开始时有两台冰箱。它们都坏了。微波炉坏了。所以我不得不买新冰箱。我不得不买新微波炉。
And my financial account-keeping was ridiculous. I had a drawer. When people paid me money for staying in the house, I'd throw it in the drawer. When there was an expense, I'd take it out of the drawer. But then I started putting my own money. Like, Marketplace would wire me my salary and I'd start putting that in the drawer. And I just was not in any serious way keeping track.
而我的财务记录简直荒唐。我有一个抽屉。当人们付钱给我住在房子里时，我会把它扔进抽屉。当有开支时，我会从抽屉里拿出来。但后来我开始放入我自己的钱。比如，市场栏目组会电汇我的工资，我就开始把它放进抽屉里。我根本没有认真地跟踪记录。
I remember there was a moment-- and this should have been a big warning sign; this should have been the sign I need to get out-- I remember spending an afternoon looking at bed and breakfast management software. There's actually an amazing number of software programs for people managing beds and breakfasts.
我记得有一个时刻——这应该是一个巨大的警示信号；这应该是需要我离开的信号——我记得花了一个下午看住宿加早餐旅馆管理软件。实际上有惊人数量的管理住宿加早餐旅馆的软件程序。
You're in the middle of a war zone looking at software to help you manage the house that you had originally decided to rent in order to make your life easier and cheaper.
你身处战争地带，却在看软件来帮助你管理你当初为了让生活更轻松、更便宜而决定租下的房子。
Yes. And all the software was like $500. I decided not to do it, but I should have.
是的。而且所有软件都要500美元。我决定不做了，但我应该做的。
But the thing that just, when I think about it even now, two and a half years later, I just get tired, what I think of is closing the door to my bedroom, closing my eyes, and someone is knocking at the door.
但让我即使在现在，两年半后想起它时，仍然感到疲惫的事情是，我想到的是关上我的卧室门，闭上眼睛，然后有人在敲门。
Bringing you a problem.
给你带来一个问题。
Bringing me a problem.
给我带来一个问题。
Journalists or Iraqis?
记者还是伊拉克人？
Journalists and Iraqis both. They would come to my door, they'd knock on my door.
记者和伊拉克人都有。他们会来到我的门前，敲我的门。
[KNOCKING SOUND]
[敲门声]
"Adam, Abu Faisal has left his truck here for three days. He's only leaving his truck here so that no other driver will come, but I want my cousin, who's a driver, to come. You have to tell Abu Faisal to leave."
“亚当，阿布·费萨尔把他的卡车停在这里三天了。他只是把卡车停在这里，这样就不会有其他司机来，但我想要我的表弟，一个司机，过来。你必须告诉阿布·费萨尔离开。”
So I go to Abu Faisal. "Abut Faisal, why is your truck here?"
所以我去找阿布·费萨尔。“阿布·费萨尔，为什么你的卡车在这里？”
"Oh, my truck's here just for you, Adam. It's just so I can be here. I want to be ready to go at 3:00 in the morning. If there's a problem, I can come rescue you and take you away."
“哦，我的卡车只是为了你在这里，亚当。这样我就可以在这里。我想在凌晨3点准备出发。如果有问题，我可以来救你并带你离开。”
How do I resolve that? I don't know who to trust. I don't know what to deal with. But I'm the guy who's going to solve it.
我该怎么解决这个问题？我不知道该信任谁。我不知道该处理什么。但我就是那个要解决它的人。
[KNOCKING SOUND]
[敲门声]
"Mr. Adam, you have given Abu Faisal the last four guests to drive, but my cousin, Abu Enmar, is a better driver than him, and he has a nicer car, and he knows Baghdad even more better than Abu Faisal. Why don't you let him drive?"
“亚当先生，你已经把最后四个客人交给阿布·费萨尔开车了，但我的表弟，阿布·恩马尔，比他开车更好，他有一辆更好的车，而且他比阿布·费萨尔更了解巴格达。你为什么不让他开车？”
"Mr. Adam, Abu Faris is telling us that you said that he can take $10 from every driver because he's managing the drivers now. Is this true?"
“亚当先生，阿布·法里斯告诉我们，你说他可以从每个司机那里拿10美元，因为他现在在管理司机。这是真的吗？”
"No."
“不。”
"Well, then you must tell Abu Faris."
“那么你必须告诉阿布·法里斯。”
"Just don't"--
“别给”——
Don't give him--
别给他——
"Just don't give him the money. Don't give him the money."
“就是别给他钱。别给他钱。”
And then the journalists.
然后是记者。
[KNOCKING SOUND]
[敲门声]
Knock on the door. "Adam, hey, sorry to bother you, man. Hey, do you know who in the press center handles questions about embeds?"
敲门。“亚当，嘿，不好意思打扰你了，伙计。嘿，你知道新闻中心谁处理嵌入式报道的问题吗？”
"Yeah. Um, hang on. I'll get you his cell phone."
“是的。嗯，等一下。我给你他的手机号码。”
And then I close my eyes.
然后我闭上眼睛。
[KNOCKING SOUND]
[敲门声]
"Adam, the internet's down again. Can you look at that?" Or, "Adam, the generator's not working and I don't know how to talk to the guard because he doesn't speak English. Can you tell him that we've got to get the generator working?"
“亚当，互联网又断了。你能看看吗？”或者，“亚当，发电机不工作了，我不知道怎么和保安说话，因为他不会说英语。你能告诉他我们要让发电机工作起来吗？”
[KNOCKING SOUND]
[敲门声]
"Adam, man, we're running low on water."
“亚当，伙计，我们的水不够了。”
"Yeah, can you get water, actually? Because I don't think you've gotten water."
“是的，你能去弄点水吗，实际上？因为我不认为你弄过水。”
"Yeah, but hey, man, I'm on deadline. I've got to"--
“是的，但嘿，伙计，我有截止日期。我必须”——
"All right, just tell your driver to get water."
“好吧，只是告诉你的司机去弄水。”
"Well, my driver doesn't know where to get water, and he doesn't know what kind of water."
“好吧，我的司机不知道去哪里弄水，他也不知道是什么样的水。”
"All right, all right. I'll take care of it."
“好吧，好吧。我会处理的。”
So here's the package of things that were happening in the house: steadily worsening security, proliferation of unexpected costs, lack of reliable accounting, and all of this stitched together with a kind of cheery American can-do spirit that completely underestimated the magnitude of what you'd taken on. Now, that all sounds very familiar.
所以这就是房子里发生的一系列事情：安全性日益恶化，意外成本激增，缺乏可靠的会计，所有这些都用一种欢快的美式“能行”精神缝合在一起，完全低估了你所承担的事情的量级。现在，这听起来很熟悉。
Yeah. I mean, I do think that my experience is a reasonable metaphor for the overall American effort there. You know, I chose the wrong staff. I chose the wrong strategy to think about this as a business. I had the wrong stance in terms of security.
是的。我的意思是，我确实认为我的经历是一个合理的隐喻，说明了美国在那里的整体努力。你知道，我选错了员工。我把这当成生意的策略选错了。我在安全方面立场选错了。
And the bombings increased. We'd hear more and more bombing. We'd hear more and more about bombings that killed people. There was a few very big car bombs. And as things got worse outside, things got more frenzied inside. And we-- I mean, I remember we shifted from beer to hard liquor. We started drinking more heavily. We started drinking to get drunk. I know that there were people in the house-- in Iraqi pharmacies, you can just walk in and buy liquid Valium-- I never did, but other people started swigging liquid Valium. There were people who were smoking a lot of hash, which I never did, but there were other people doing that.
而且爆炸增加了。我们听到越来越多的爆炸声。我们听到越来越多关于爆炸炸死人的消息。有几次非常大的汽车炸弹。随着外面情况变得越来越糟，内部变得越来越疯狂。我们——我的意思是，我记得我们从喝啤酒改成了喝烈酒。我们开始喝得更多。我们开始酗酒。我知道房子里有人——在伊拉克药店，你可以直接走进去买液态安定——我从来没做过，但其他人开始狂饮液态安定。有人抽了很多大麻，我也没做过，但有其他人这样做。
I think that's a combination of things. I mean, I think part of it is the outside got worse. We were living in a much more dangerous environment. So obviously, it just causes tension. Optimism was plummeting. If the first six months or so after the fall of Baghdad it was reasonable to think, "you know, things aren't going that well, but someone's going to figure it out, it's going to get back on track," it no longer seemed reasonable. It seemed pretty clear that things were going to get worse and worse and worse. And obviously they have.
我认为那是多种因素的结合。我的意思是，我认为部分原因是外界变得更糟。我们生活在一个危险得多的环境中。所以显然，它只是导致了紧张。乐观情绪正在暴跌。如果说巴格达陷落后的前六个月左右，认为“你知道，情况进展得不是很好，但有人会解决它，它会回到正轨”是合理的，那么它看起来就不再合理了。看起来很清楚，事情只会变得越来越糟，越来越糟。而且显然确实如此。
So this is actually the point in your stay in Baghdad when I went to Baghdad to report there for about a month. And you were excited about your house. You showed me all around the house. And I saw you, over the course of this month, get scared. And it seemed like a few things happened in rapid succession that really spooked you.
所以这实际上是你待在巴格达时我过去报道大约一个月的时间。你对你的房子很兴奋。你带我参观了整栋房子。我看到你，在这一个月里，变得害怕了。而且似乎发生了一些事情，连续发生，真的把你吓坏了。
There were some specific things that happened to me, personally. One thing is I had a leading tribal sheik whose tribe is in Anbar province, whose tribe is one of the tribes fighting the Americans. And I thought of him as a good friend, and he was my escape valve. I'd already worked it out: if things get really bad, he was going to smuggle me out of the country and take care of me. And two people came up to me, two separate people came up to me and said, "you know, that sheik who you're friends with, he's telling people you're a CIA agent.
有一些具体的事情发生在我个人身上。一件事是，我有一个领先的部落谢赫，他的部落在安巴尔省，他的部落是那些与美国人作战的部落之一。我把他当作好朋友，他是我的逃生阀。我已经算好了：如果情况变得非常糟糕，他会把我偷运出境并照顾我。然后两个人走到我面前，两个不同的人走到我面前说，“你知道，那个你引以为豪的朋友，那个谢赫，他在告诉别人你是中情局特工。”
Oh my god.
天哪。
Which for many parts of Iraq, that's a death sentence. You don't want anyone to think you're a CIA agent. I now think that he was actually showing off, but it's a weird way to show off since it put my life at risk. So that was very scary.
这在伊拉克的许多地方，是死刑判决。你不想让任何人认为你是中情局特工。我现在认为他实际上是在炫耀，但这是一种奇怪的炫耀方式，因为它把我的生命置于危险之中。所以这非常可怕。
Then this driver, the driver who wanted to be the head driver of our house, he had left his big SUV in our driveway. And because the other drivers got mad, I forced him to take the SUV out. And the driver community, the foreign press driver community in Iraq was small enough, the way I put it together now, he felt kind of humiliated that he got kicked out of my house. And so he didn't want to tell other people that he left because I told him to. He told people, "oh, I left because Adam's house is under surveillance and the insurgents are going to attack it." I don't think that was true, but I was getting-- people were telling me that. And it's pretty terrifying when people start telling you your house could be attacked.
然后这个司机，那个想成为我们房子首席司机的司机，他把他那辆大SUV留在了我们的车道上。因为其他司机生气了，我强迫他把SUV开走。而司机社区，伊拉克外国媒体司机社区足够小，我想法是，他觉得被踢出我的房子有点丢脸。所以他不想告诉别人他离开是因为我让他离开。他告诉人们，“哦，我离开是因为亚当的房子受到监视，叛乱分子要攻击它。”我不认为那是真的，但我当时正在——人们在告诉我这些。当你开始听到人们说你的房子可能会被攻击时，这相当可怕。
And in a weird way, the scariest thing was this: I was at the Hamrah Hotel having drinks with some friends and I had to go home, and I got a cab. And I got in the cab. And I speak Arabic pretty well. I was telling him where my house was. And it was a cab driver, I've never seen this guy before in my life. And I'm telling him where my house is, and he says, "oh, you mean Mr. Adam's house." And I just found that absolutely chilling. This man I've never seen before, doesn't know I'm Mr. Adam, knows where Mr. Adam's house is.
而且在某种奇怪的方式下，最可怕的事情是这个：我在哈姆拉酒店和一些朋友喝酒，我不得不回家，我叫了一辆出租车。我上了出租车。我阿拉伯语说得很好。我告诉他我的房子在哪里。那是出租车司机，我这辈子从没见过这个人。我告诉他我的房子在哪里，他说，“哦，你是说亚当先生的房子。”我感到完全不寒而栗。这个我从未见过的人，不知道我是亚当先生，却知道亚当先生的房子在哪里。
Because up to this point, you'd thought-- your security plan was to sort of fly under the radar.
因为到目前为止，你认为——你的安全计划是某种低调行事。
Right. The whole point of the house was, if there's some insurgent who wants to kidnap or kill an American journalist, he's going to go to the hotel. I'm going to be off in a neighborhood somewhere. He doesn't even know where I am. So to find out--
对。房子的全部意义在于，如果有叛乱分子想要绑架或杀害一名美国记者，他会去酒店。我会在某个地方的街区。他甚至不知道我在哪。所以发现——
That a random cab driver--
一个随意的出租车司机——
That a random cab driver knows where my house is, knows that there's a Western journalist named Mr. Adam living in this house, that means a lot of people know that. And that means that if there's an insurgent out there who wants to kidnap or kill an American, why go to a hotel which has all this security when you can just go to this house? And that was really terrifying to me.
一个随意的出租车司机知道我的房子在哪里，知道有一个叫亚当先生的西方记者住在这栋房子里，这意味着很多人知道这一点。这意味着如果外面有一个叛乱分子想要绑架或杀害美国人，为什么要去那个有所有这些安保的酒店，当你可以直接去这栋房子时？那对我来说真的非常可怕。
And then a bunch of other things happened. This was about the year anniversary of the war. I think people were very fed up. It's right around the time where it just felt like the whole country was sort of realizing, oh, man, there's just no hope.
然后又发生了一堆其他事情。那是在战争一周年纪念日左右。我认为人们非常受够了。就在那个时候，感觉整个国家都在意识到，哦，伙计，根本没有希望了。
And then the Mount Lebanon Hotel--
然后黎巴嫩山酒店——
The Mount Lebanon Hotel bombing, which I think was the first day you were there.
黎巴嫩山酒店爆炸案，我认为那是你在那里的第一天。
And I remember you were talking to Iraqi kids-- there were some young boys who were playing around there-- and they were saying, "oh, the Americans did this. The Americans."
我记得你在和伊拉克孩子谈话——那里有一些年轻男孩在玩耍——他们说，“哦，是美国人做的。美国人。”
Yeah, everybody. It was this weird thing where--
是的，每个人。这是一种奇怪的事情，——
I mean, "the Americans had bombed the hotel." This is what they were saying.
我的意思是，“美国人轰炸了酒店。”这是他们说的。
That the Americans had bombed the hotel. I remember there was this huge crater. There were car parts everywhere in this crater. It was so obviously a car bomb.
说美国人轰炸了酒店。我记得有一个巨大的弹坑。弹坑里到处都是汽车零件。那显然是一个汽车炸弹。
But everyone was saying it was an American RPG.
但每个人都说是美国的RPG。
And everyone was saying it was an American missile. And I remember one guy saying, "if this had been a car bomb, you'd see car parts. Why are there no car parts?" I'm like, "but there's nothing but car parts." He's like, "oh, no. That's from a different car."
而且每个人都说是美国的导弹。我记得有一个家伙说，“如果这是汽车炸弹，你会看到汽车零件。为什么没有汽车零件？”我说，“但除了汽车零件什么都没有。”他说，“哦，不。那是来自另一辆车的。”
And there was sort of an angry crowd.
然后有一群愤怒的人群。
It was the first crowd of Iraqis angry at us. Not angry--
那是第一群对我们愤怒的伊拉克人。不是愤怒——
About the bombing.
关于爆炸。
About the bombing and telling us about it, but angry at us. That felt scary.
关于爆炸，并告诉我们这件事，但对我们愤怒。那感觉很可怕。
And then, one of my friends, who's like a much more seasoned war correspondent, sat me down and said, "because you've had all these American officials at your house, this house is a legitimate military target."
然后，我的一位朋友，像是一个更资深的战地记者，坐下来对我说，“因为你有这么多美国官员在你的房子里，这栋房子是一个合法的军事目标。”
Because you were bringing people from the Coalition Provisional Authority. You were bringing soldiers.
因为你把联盟临时管理处的人带进来了。你带来了士兵。
We were bringing the occupational forces to our house. And we were one of the few unprotected places in Baghdad where people had seen American-- could have seen. I don't know if anyone did see, but could have seen American officials.
我们把占领军带到了我们的房子里。我们是巴格达为数不多的不受保护的地方之一，人们看到了美国——可能看到过。我不知道有没有人真的看到，但可能看到过美国官员。
And when this guy who said this to you, did you think, "you know, I was thinking of myself as separate from the occupation and other people. Iraqis are sort of mistaking me as being part of it?" And did you realize, "oh, wait, I'm part of this in some way that I hadn't understood up until now or I hadn't wanted to see or accept?"
当这个对你说这话的人说的时候，你有没有想，“你知道，我一直认为自己与占领和其他人分开。伊拉克人某种程度上误以为我是其中的一部分？”你有没有意识到，“哦，等等，我以某种我直到现在都没有理解或者我不想看到或接受的方式参与其中？”
I certainly started to get that that's how Iraqis perceived. I think for all my difference-- learning Iraqi Arabic, living in the city, becoming friends with Iraqis, traveling the city-- you know, I misread the place pretty badly. I ended up making some really bad calls.
我当然开始意识到伊拉克人是这样看待的。我认为尽管我有所有不同——学习伊拉克阿拉伯语，住在城市里，与伊拉克人成为朋友，在城市旅行——你知道，我把这个地方读错了。我最终做出了几个非常糟糕的决定。
And it's also funny. Like, we don't get Shiites and Sunnis and Kurds. We don't get the difference between a kind of poorly educated Shiite who lives in Sadr City as different from a middle class Shiite who lives in [? Qadisiya. ?] These are all things completely lost to the Americans. But to the Iraqis, they don't get us. You know, they don't get that some Americans are Republican loyalists, and others are anti-war activists, and others are journalists who really want to just know the truth. Just like we don't understand them, they don't understand us.
而且这很有趣。比如，我们不懂什叶派、逊尼派和库尔德人。我们不懂居住在萨德尔城的受教育程度较低的什叶派与居住在卡迪西亚的中产阶级什叶派之间的区别。这些对美国人来说完全丢失了。但对伊拉克人来说，他们不懂我们。你知道，他们不懂有些美国人是共和党死忠，有些是反战活动家，有些是只想了解真相的记者。就像我们不了解他们，他们也不了解我们。
Adam Davidson with Nancy Updike. Since returning to America, Adam joined the staff of NPR's daily news programs. He now covers the global economy for them. He wrote about his house in Baghdad in Harper's Magazine.
亚当·戴维森与南希·厄普代克。回到美国后，亚当加入了NPR日常新闻节目的员工团队。他现在为他们报道全球经济。他在《哈珀杂志》上写了他在巴格达的房子。
Coming up, when the plan you invented for yourself at 11 years old ends up dominating the rest of your life. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，当你11岁时为自己发明的计划最终占据了你余生的时候。那将在稍后播出，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, My Brilliant Plan, stories of plans that arrive in a flash of inspiration, and then what happens to them.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的各种各样的故事。今天的节目《我的天才计划》，那些在一瞬间灵感中到来的计划，以及后来它们发生了什么的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two, Tragedy Minus Time Equals Happily Ever After. OK, so there's this guy and he has a very simple problem: he wants to see his dead father again. And he comes up with what is possibly the world's most complicated solution to this problem. It's so complicated that to fully understand his solution, you would need to master the following disciplines.
我们到达了第二幕，悲剧减去时间等于从此幸福快乐。好吧，所以有这么个人，他有一个非常简单的问题：他想再见他死去的父亲一面。他想出了可能是世界上解决这个问题最复杂的方案。它是如此复杂，以至于要完全理解他的解决方案，你需要精通以下学科。
Ordinary calculus, or multi-variable calculus, differential equations, partial differential equations, vector analysis, vector calculus, matrix analysis, tensor calculus, group theory, and, oh, Green's functions.
普通微积分，或者多元微积分，微分方程，偏微分方程，向量分析，向量微积分，矩阵分析，张量微积分，群论，还有，哦，格林函数。
Right, and that's just the math. You also need to know physics, theoretical mechanics, electrodynamics, quantum mechanics and general relativity. If you know all of these things, you'd be able to get what he's done, which is to take the first baby step in maybe getting to see his father again. OK, here it is, his invention.
对，那还只是数学。你还需要了解物理学、理论力学、电动力学、量子力学和广义相对论。如果你了解所有这些东西，你就能得到他所做的，也就是在可能再次见到他父亲方面迈出的第一小步。好吧，就是这个，他的发明。
Omega is equal to g times row divided by a times cq. This is the key equation.
Omega等于g乘以row除以a乘以c的立方。这是关键方程。
Josh Gleason explains this very complicated and brilliant plan, and what all this means.
乔什·格里森解释了这个极其复杂和天才的计划，以及所有这一切意味着什么。
Actually, even before you understand the math and the physics and the seemingly impossible goal that Ron Mallett has spent more than 50 years trying to achieve, you need to understand something much simpler, which is how much Ron loved his dad, Boyd Mallett. Lots of 10-year-old boys feel like there's nothing their Dad can't do, but in Ron's case, there was hard evidence. He wired their train set to obey voice commands. At parties in their Bronx apartment, he'd rig the toilet so that when someone opened the lid, music would play. He had helped wire the new United Nations building in Manhattan, but his main job was fixing TVs and radios.
实际上，甚至在你理解数学和物理学以及罗恩·马利特花费了超过50年试图实现那个看似不可能的目标之前，你需要理解一些更简单的事情，那就是罗恩有多爱他的爸爸，博伊德·马利特。许多10岁的男孩觉得没有什么是他们爸爸做不到的，但在罗恩的情况下，有确凿证据。他给他们的火车模型接线以响应语音指令。在布朗克斯公寓的聚会上，他会改装马桶，以便有人打开盖子时，音乐就会响起。他帮助给曼哈顿新建的联合国大楼布线，但他主要的工作是修理电视和收音机。
Ron adored his father so much that he says his day only really began in the evenings when his dad came home from work. He'd meet him at the subway and carry his toolbox home.
罗恩如此崇拜他的父亲，以至于他说他的一天真正开始是在晚上他爸爸下班回家的时候。他会去地铁站接他，并把他的工具箱搬回家。
As the oldest son, I felt like the heir apparent, and he treated me that way. In fact, as I got older, he would actually take me and show me the parts of the television set. I can remember him telling me about the yolk that was supporting the television tube and everything. So he was actually grooming me to be part of his world. So that there was just, for me, this aura around him. It's like a prince around the king.
作为长子，我觉得自己像是王位继承人，他就是那样对待我的。事实上，随着我长大，他实际上会带我向我展示电视机的部件。我记得他告诉我关于支撑电视显像管的磁轭以及所有东西。所以他实际上是在培养我成为他世界的一部分。所以对我来说，他周围有一种光环。就像围绕国王的王子。
On the night of his parents' 11th wedding anniversary, after a party at their house, Ron woke up to the sound of his mother crying. He wandered into his parents' bedroom and saw his father lying dead on the bed. He'd had a massive heart attack. For Ron, this was almost impossible to comprehend. He was 10 years old. It was like Superman had just died.
在他父母结婚11周年的那个晚上，在他们家举办聚会后，罗恩被他母亲哭泣的声音吵醒。他走进父母的卧室，看到他的父亲躺在床上已经死了。他心脏病发作了。对罗恩来说，这几乎无法理解。他当时10岁。就像超人刚刚死了一样。
I don't know. It's so hard to describe the feeling of anguish and total loss that I felt, even then. It was just like he was the most important thing in my life. He was the center of my universe. So, if he had said, you know, "will you come with me," and I knew that that would be the end of everything for me, I would have gone gladly without even a second's hesitation.
我不知道。真的很难描述即使在那时我感到的痛苦和完全的失落的感觉。他就像是我生命中最重要的事情。他是我的宇宙中心。所以，如果他说，你知道，“你愿意跟我走吗”，而我知道那对我来说意味着一切的终结，我会毫不犹豫地愉快地跟随。
Ron became a different kid after that. He stopped being interested in friends or school. He stopped caring about pretty much everything. The only thing he wanted to do was read. His dad had introduced him to this series of comics called Classics Illustrated based on classic books. And it was one of these comics that led to his big plan, the plan that would become the focus of his life for the next 50 years.
在那之后，罗恩成了一个不同的孩子。他不再对朋友或学校感兴趣。他几乎不再关心任何事情。他唯一想做的事就是阅读。他爸爸向他介绍了一系列名为《经典连环画》的漫画，基于经典书籍。正是这些漫画之一引导他走上了大计划，这个计划将成为未来50年他生活的重心。
The comic was The Time Machine, based on the book by H.G. Wells, and Ron remembers the moment he first saw it on the rack at the drugstore. On the cover was a picture of this guy working on a futuristic machine that had wires and tubes coming out of it. And there were a bunch of tools laying around, the same tools that Ron's dad had used. In fact, the picture looked incredibly similar to one Ron had of his father working behind a giant TV set.
漫画是《时间机器》，基于H.G.威尔斯的书，罗恩记得他第一次在药店货架上看到它的时刻。封面上是一张那个家伙正在研究一台未来机器的照片，上面有电线和管子出来。周围放着一堆工具，正是罗恩爸爸用过的那些工具。事实上，这张照片看起来非常像罗恩有的他父亲在一台巨大电视机后面工作的一张照片。
And I still remember reading those words that were in there on the first page of it, saying that time is a kind of space and we can go forward and backward in time just as we can in space. And that hit me. I mean, that hit me so hard. I knew immediately what that would have to mean, that if you had a machine that could travel forward in time and backward in time, then, with that machine, I could go back in time, when my father was still alive. I have to say, that was the defining moment, besides my father's death, of my life, was seeing that comic. And I remember getting it and reading it cover to cover again and again and again. And I felt, this is it. This is it. This is the key. This is the thing that I have to do. I have to find a way of building a time machine. And that became my goal. It became my total obsession.
我还记得读到书的第一页上写的那些话，说时间是一种空间，我们可以像在空间中一样在时间中前进和后退。那击中了我的心。我的意思是，那击中我太深了。我立刻就知道那必须意味着什么，如果你有一台可以在时间中前进和后退的机器，那么，有了那台机器，我就能回到过去，那时我的父亲还活着。我必须说，除了我父亲的去世，那是我生命中决定性的时刻，就是看到那本漫画。我记得买下它，一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地从头到尾阅读它。我感到，就是这个。就是这个。这是关键。这是我必须做的事。我必须找到建造时间机器的方法。那成了我的目标。它成了我彻底的执念。
Fascinating. What is it?
太迷人了。这是什么？
This is only a small experimental model, of course.
这只是一个小实验模型，当然。
Ron saw the movie version of the book five times.
罗恩把这本书的电影版本看了五遍。
To carry a man, a larger edition is needed.
为了携带一个人，需要一个更大的版本。
To carry a man? Where?
为了携带一个人？去哪里？
Into the past or into the future.
回到过去或去往未来。
He always sat fifth row center, always alone. He recognized from the moment he got his idea that it had to be a secret. Like I said, he'd read a lot of these Classics Illustrateds, including some based on Shakespeare.
他总是坐在第五排中间，总是独自一人。从他有了这个想法的那一刻起，他就意识到这必须是一个秘密。就像我说的，他读过很多这些《经典连环画》，包括一些基于莎士比亚的。
I knew Hamlet. I actually knew what it meant when people thought that people were crazy. And I knew that that was not a thing that you wanted to have people know about you, and I thought people would think that this was crazy.
我知道哈姆雷特。我实际上知道当人们认为人们疯了是什么意思。我知道那不是你希望人们知道关于你的事情，我想人们会认为这很疯狂。
First, let me tell you how it works. Here, in this compartment, you see the saddle where the time traveler sits. Forward pressure sends the machine into the future, backward pressure into the past.
首先，让我告诉你它是如何工作的。在这里，在这个隔间里，你看到时间旅行者坐的座位。向前压力将机器送向未来，向后压力送向过去。
So Ron started building his time machine on the sly, down in the basement. Not even his brothers knew what he was doing. He figured if he could build a machine that looked exactly like the picture on the cover of the book, it would work. He would go back in time and warn his father that he was going to die if he didn't take care of his heart problem.
所以罗恩开始在地下室偷偷地建造他的时间机器。甚至他的兄弟们都不知道他在做什么。他想如果他能建造一台看起来和书封面上那张照片一模一样的机器，它就能工作。他将回到过去并警告他的父亲，如果他不照顾好他的心脏问题，他就会死。
He went to the junkyard and started collecting things: tire rims, a bicycles seat, anything that looked like the stuff on the comic book cover. He raided his dad's old equipment, picking out wires, vacuum tubes, an old radio chassis. For weeks he'd rushed home from school so he could work on the time machine. Finally, he was done.
他去了垃圾场，开始收集东西：轮胎圈，自行车座，任何看起来像漫画封面上那些东西的东西。他洗劫了他爸爸的旧设备，挑选出电线、真空管、旧收音机机箱。几周来，他放学后就匆忙回家，这样他就可以研究时间机器。终于，他完成了。
I thought that this was going to work, because you know, if I plugged it in, just like my father when he would work on the sets-- when he plugged it in, it worked-- this was going to work. And there was a cord and I plugged it in, and it was nothing. I was disappointed. But the thing is, is that that's when I began to think, you know, I've got to read the story again. That's when I decided to go to the real book. Because I figured, well, maybe there's not enough details in the Classic Illustrated, so if I go to the original book, it'll have more detailed instructions.
我以为这会工作，因为你知道，如果我把它插上电源，就像我父亲研究电视机时那样——当他插上电源，它就工作了——这也会工作。有一根电线，我把它插上电源，结果什么都没有。我感到失望。但问题是，那就是我开始思考的时候，你知道，我得再读一遍这个故事。那时我决定去读真正的书。因为我想，好吧，也许《经典连环画》里细节不够多，如果我去看原著，它会有更详细的说明。
This is the part of the story where kids like you and me and kids like Ron part ways, because most kids would give up at this point, but Ron didn't do that. Instead, he became even more determined to figure out a way to build a time machine. He struggled through the adult version of Wells's book, and this was a kid who had pretty much given up on school. He began spending his lunch money on science paperbacks at the local Salvation Army. This left him eating so little and getting so scrawny that he eventually became anemic, and his mom had to start packing him lunches.
这是故事中像你我这样的孩子和像罗恩这样的孩子分道扬镳的部分，因为大多数孩子此时会放弃，但罗恩没有那样做。相反，他变得更加坚定地要找出建造时间机器的方法。他努力读完了威尔斯书的成人版，而这是一个几乎放弃了学校的孩子。他开始把午餐钱花在当地救世军书店的科学平装书上。这导致他吃得很少，变得很瘦，以至于他最终贫血了，他的妈妈不得不开始给他打包午餐。
Here's the other unusual thing about Ron. He's the rare person whose life was shaped almost entirely by books, one after the other. In fact, nearly every big change in his life, every major decision, can be traced directly to something he read. When he was 12, for instance, he found a copy of The Universe and Dr. Einstein. He had heard the name Einstein before, and the book had a picture of an hourglass on the cover, which he knew was a symbol for time.
关于罗恩的另一件不同寻常的事情是。他是极少数几乎完全被书籍塑造的人，一本接一本。事实上，他生活中几乎每一个巨大的变化，每一个重大决定，都可以直接追溯到他读过的东西。比如，当他12岁时，他发现了一本《宇宙与爱因斯坦》。他之前听说过爱因斯坦这个名字，而且书的封面上有一个沙漏的图片，他知道那是时间的象征。
For me, the notion of time was abstract. But then, in this book, it actually represented-- this is going to sound like a very simple thing-- but it represented time by a symbol: t. That was the next important thing in my life, because here was an articulation. It made time no longer an abstract concept. It made time an object. And what it said in the book was that-- which, I didn't understand the equation, now don't get me wrong. I didn't understand the equation, but I understood that Einstein said that time could be changed by motion. So you asked, why didn't I think it was crazy. It was because everyone said this great genius Einstein, you know, he knows everything, if he says time can be changed, then time can be changed and a time machine is possible.
对我来说，时间的概念是抽象的。但后来，在这本书中，它实际上代表了——这听起来会是一件很简单的事情——但它用一个符号表示时间：t。那是我生命中下一个重要的事，因为这里有一个清晰的表述。它使时间不再是一个抽象的概念。它使时间成为一个物体。而书中说的是——我当时没理解那个方程，现在别误会我。我不理解方程，但我理解爱因斯坦说时间可以通过运动来改变。所以你问，为什么我不认为它疯狂。那是因为每个人都说这位伟大的天才爱因斯坦，你知道，他无所不知，如果他说时间可以被改变，那么时间就可以被改变，时间机器是可能的。
The equation he's talking about here is called the Lorentz transformation, and Ron treated it like some holy mantra. He wrote it all over his school notebooks. Needless to say, he wasn't very popular. In fact, he had no friends at all. He was a nerd who couldn't even hang out with other nerds.
他在谈论的这个方程被称为洛伦兹变换，罗恩把它当作某种神圣的咒语对待。他把它写在他所有的学校笔记本上。不用说，他不太受欢迎。事实上，他根本没有朋友。他是一个甚至无法和其他书呆子混在一起的书呆子。
In the school, there would have been other nerds, but I was an African American kid. I was not in the upper-- I wasn't in that income group where I would have been able to run with the white nerds of the-- you know what I'm saying? You see what I'm saying? You have to remember, we're talking about the '50s here. And the white community had the key club and the science club, and I was not a part of any of these groups.
在学校里，本来会有其他书呆子，但我是一个非裔美国孩子。我不在上层——我不在那个收入阶层，我无法和那里的白人书呆子混在一起——你知道我在说什么吗？你明白我的意思吗？你必须记住，我们是在谈论50年代。白人社区有关键俱乐部和科学俱乐部，我不是这些群体的一部分。
Ron forced himself to study math and electronics, all in the service of the time machine. When he finished high school, he immediately enlisted in the Air Force so he could go to college on the G.I. Bill. He trained as an electrical engineer and read whatever he could get his hands on, anything that seemed like it might help him figure out how time worked, even books he really had no hope of understanding, as if he could absorb them by sheer force of will. Eventually, he learned enough to realize that he was on the wrong track. It wasn't electronics he needed to know. It was something called quantum mechanics. He needed to become a physicist.
罗恩强迫自己学习数学和电子学，所有这些都是为了时间机器服务的。当他高中毕业时，他立即应征入伍，这样他就可以用退伍军人权利法案去上大学。他接受了电气工程师培训，并阅读了他能拿到的任何东西，任何看起来可能有助于他弄清楚时间如何运作的东西，甚至是他完全没有希望理解的书，好像他能通过纯粹的意志力吸收它们。最终，他学到了足够多的东西，意识到他走错了方向。他需要知道的不是电子学。而是被称为量子力学的东西。他需要成为一名物理学家。
He got his PhD and became a tenured professor at the University of Connecticut. And somewhere along the way, he figured out how to talk to women and got married. But all this time, he never forgot about the time machine. You'd think that the more he learned, the more ridiculous his idea might seem to him, but the opposite happened. Every shred of information he collected seemed to confirm that time travel may be possible.
他获得了博士学位，并成为康涅狄格大学的终身教授。在此期间，他从未忘记过时间机器。你可能会认为他学到的越多，他的想法对他来说就越荒谬，但相反的情况发生了。他收集到的每一片信息似乎都在证实时间旅行可能是可能的。
While he felt comfortable telling his wife about his dream, he never told anyone at the university. Already he was worried about being taken seriously in the physics world as an African American. But to be a black physicist obsessed with time travel, that seemed like a double whammy he could never get away with. Since he couldn't do out-and-out research on time travel, he became an expert in the next best thing: black holes, which had been shown to twist time. But after a couple decades studying cosmic solutions-- worm holes, cosmic strings-- his plan was stalled, and Ron was getting discouraged.
虽然他觉得告诉妻子他的梦想很舒服，但他从未告诉大学里的任何人。他已经担心作为一个非裔美国人在物理学界被严肃对待的问题。但作为一个痴迷于时间旅行的黑人物理学家，那似乎是他永远无法摆脱的双重打击。既然他不能进行彻底的时间旅行研究，他成了下一个最好的事情的专家：黑洞，已经被证明可以扭曲时间。但在研究了几十年宇宙解决方案——虫洞，宇宙弦——之后，他的计划陷入了停滞，罗恩感到灰心丧气。
It's great if you have a way of harnessing a worm hole or a black hole or cosmic strings, but these are things out there. I wanted something that would be in a laboratory, something that would be a device, something that was close to the time traveler in The Time Machine. So that was the problem, and I didn't feel like I was getting closer to that. And it was driving me to distraction.
如果你有利用虫洞或黑洞或宇宙弦的方法，那很好，但这些都是外面的东西。我想要一些在实验室里的东西，一些装置，一些接近《时间机器》中时间旅行者的东西。所以那就是问题所在，我不觉得我离那更近了。它正把我逼向疯狂。
You might say it was sort of a desert period. If you looked at what was happening in my professional life, I mean, I was publishing, I got my professorship. But if you looked at what was happening to me inside of my personal life, I was beginning to emotionally shut down. I began thinking I had been wasting all of my life, that this goal of the time machine was not something that was achievable.
你可能会说那是一段沙漠时期。如果你看我的职业生涯中发生了什么，我的意思是，我在发表论文，我得到了教授职位。但如果你看我的个人生活中发生了什么，我的情绪开始关闭。我开始认为我浪费了我的一生，那个时间机器的目标并不是一个可实现的目标。
Even his wife, Dorothy, who had been supportive of his obsession all these years, couldn't console him.
甚至他的妻子多萝西，这么多年来一直支持他的执念，也无法安慰他。
I would come home and she would ask me how things were going, and I would just simply say, OK. And then I would go up to my room to go to bed and lay there all the rest of the night, and not talk to her.
我会回到家，她会问我情况如何，我只会简单地说，好吧。然后我会上楼去我的房间睡觉，整晚躺在那里，不和她说话。
And think about what?
去思考什么？
And actually just think about how wasted my life felt, how what I was doing just wasn't meaningful, and just that I just failed myself. And I just-- you know, I was listening to old Simon & Garfunkel songs.
其实只是思考我的生活感到多么浪费，我所做的事情多么没有意义，以及我只是辜负了自己。我只是——你知道，我在听西蒙和加芬克尔的老歌。
Like what songs?
比如什么歌？
Oh, you know, "Hello Darkness, my old friend. I've come to talk to you again." You know, things like that.
哦，你知道，“你好，黑暗，我的老朋友。我又来找你谈话了。”你知道，诸如此类。
[MUSIC - "THE SOUNDS OF SILENCE" BY SIMON & GARFUNKEL]
[音乐 - 西蒙和加芬克尔的《寂静之声》]
You have to remember, here I am, from 11 all the way up through the service, all the way up-- I mean, my identity is wrapped up in this thing, this time machine. I mean, that's my identity now. To lose that dream was now like losing my identity. Because my identity-- if I don't have this goal of the time machine, then what do I have? And that was it. It was like, nothing.
你必须记住，在这里，从11岁一直到服役，一直到——我的身份和这个东西——时间机器——纠缠在一起。我的意思是，那是我的身份现在。失去那个梦想现在就像失去我的身份。因为我的身份——如果我没有这个时间机器的目标，那么我有什么？就是这样。就像，什么都没有。
He hadn't built a time machine, but all the years of trying to build it had basically accomplished the same thing: it let him live in the past. He imagined the scene over and over, what it would be like to see his father again. He'd knock at the apartment door, 11B, and see this young guy, now both shorter and younger than himself, and calmly tell him that although he knew it sounded crazy, time travel was possible. He'd mention Einstein and use TV as an analogy, how sending pictures through space wasn't all that different from sending people through time. And then he'd show him family photos. He'd say, "this is your family in the future."
他没有制造出一台时间机器，但他多年来试图制造它基本上完成了同样的事情：它让他活在过去。他一次又一次地想象那个场景，再次见到他父亲会是什么样子。他会敲开11B的门，看到这个年轻人，现在比他自己又矮又年轻，并冷静地告诉他，虽然他知道这听起来很疯狂，但时间旅行是可能的。他会提到爱因斯坦并把电视作为类比，把图片通过空间发送与把人通过时间发送并没有什么不同。然后他会展示家庭照片。他会说，“这是你未来的家人。”
"One of the things I'm trying to tell you is that you are not in these pictures, later pictures. And the reason why you're not is the reason why I'm here." And I would say, "you know, I know that you're going to have a hard time understanding or believing this, but I am your son. I am your son. And I come from another time. And I'm here to tell you that you are going to die, and you're going to die in the near future. And that's why you're not in these pictures. These are pictures of your family without you. And the reason that you're not is because of the fact that you smoke two packs of cigarettes a day, you don't take care of yourself, you've got a very weak heart. If you change, you will live. And that's what I've come here to tell you."
“我试图告诉你的一件事是，你不在这些照片里，后来的照片里。而你不在的原因就是我在这里的原因。”我会说，“你知道，我知道你很难理解或相信这一点，但我就是你的儿子。我是你的儿子。我来自另一个时间。我来这里告诉你，你要死了，而且你很快就会死。这就是为什么你不在这些照片里。这些是没有你的家人的照片。而你不在的原因是因为你每天抽两包烟，你不照顾自己，你有一个非常虚弱的心脏。如果你改变，你就会活下来。这就是我来这里要告诉你的。”
And the thing is, is that I would hope that I would convince him of that, but I also know that there's a chance that he might not believe me. I also know that one of the other things I would tell him, which I know that I never had a chance to tell him when I was a child, is that I loved him. And of course, just the physical thing of seeing him real and alive and hearing that voice again that I only heard, can really remember from audio tapes, just to hear that again.
问题是，我希望我会说服他相信这一点，但我也知道他有可能不相信我。我也知道我会告诉他的另一件事，我知道我小时候从来没有机会告诉他，那就是我爱他。当然，仅仅是看到他真实地活着并再次听到那个声音，那个我只在录音带里听到、真正能记住的声音，仅仅是再次听到那个声音。
[TYPING SOUNDS]
[打字声]
So what you're going to see here are four intersecting laser beams that will be making up a ring laser, but you'll be seeing-- how many layers were you able to get?
所以你在这里看到的是四条交叉的激光束，它们将组成一个环形激光器，但你会看到——你能够得到多少层？
One, two, three, four.
一，二，三，四。
You were able to get four layers?
你能够得到四层？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, fantastic.
哦，太棒了。
When he was 57, Ron finally made his time machine, or at least a model, anyway. He showed it to me in his lab in the woods, and the fact that it exists at all is sort of surprising. Through most of his 40s, he got more and more despondent. His marriage had broken up and he'd basically given up on the time machine. To give himself something new to focus on, he married again and concentrated on his new family. But then heart problems forced him to take a medical leave from the university. He realized he couldn't stand the thought of dying without giving the time machine one last shot. He threw himself again into research.
当他57岁时，罗恩终于制造了他的时间机器，或者至少是一个模型。他在森林里的实验室向我展示了它，它确实存在这一事实让人有点吃惊。在他40多岁的大部分时间里，他变得越来越沮丧。他的婚姻破裂了，他基本上放弃了时间机器。为了让自己有新的重心，他再次结婚并专注于他的新家庭。但后来心脏问题迫使他从大学申请了病假。他意识到他无法忍受在没有给时间机器最后一次尝试的情况下就死去的想法。他再次全身心投入到研究中。
if you look up through here, you actually can see down through the center of the square. That's where the neutron would be coming up through.
如果你往这里看，你实际上可以看到正方形中心下方。那就是中子会从那里上来的地方。
Ron worked for weeks and weeks solving hundreds of equations by hand, using number two pencils on legal pads, sometimes for 15 hours a day, and ended up with a four-page paper which presented that equation you heard at the beginning of the story. Omega is equal to g times row divided by a times c cubed, which basically says that light, not just matter, can affect gravity, which could lead to a twisting of time. This model is the practical result of his math. It's about the size of a blender, a cylinder with four layers of red light beams shining through it. The idea is that the small, high intensity rings of light can actually alter gravity within the machine, sort of like a spoon stirring coffee in a cup. And as Einstein said, when you alter gravity, you affect time.
罗恩花了几个星期的时间亲手解开了数百个方程，在法律垫上用2号铅笔，有时每天工作15小时，最后得出了一篇四页的论文，提出了你在故事开头听到的那个方程。Omega等于g乘以row除以a乘以c的立方，它基本上说光，不仅仅是物质，可以影响引力，这可能导致时间的扭曲。这个模型是他数学的实际结果。它大约是一个搅拌机的大小，一个中间有四层红光束射出的圆柱体。想法是小的高强度光环实际上可以改变机器内的引力，有点像勺子在杯子里搅拌咖啡。正如爱因斯坦所说，当你改变引力时，你就影响了时间。
To test the machine, you drop in a neutron, like dropping a sugar cube into that same cup of swirling coffee, and see what happens. This is only a small experimental model, of course. To carry a man, a larger edition is needed.
要测试机器，你投入一个中子，就像把糖块放入同一杯旋转的咖啡中，看看会发生什么。这只是一个小实验模型，当然。为了携带一个人，需要一个更大的版本。
Ron published his findings. And even though the idea was only a theoretical basis for a time machine, nowhere near the actual thing, it turned out that people were really, really interested in time machines. The magazine New Scientist ran a cover article on him. After more than 40 years of working in secret, Ron was finally out of the closet as a guy who was seriously studying time travel.
罗恩发表了他的发现。尽管这个想法只是时间机器的理论基础，离实际的东西还很远，但结果证明人们真的、真的对时间机器感兴趣。《新科学家》杂志刊登了一篇关于他的封面文章。在秘密工作了40多年后，罗恩终于作为一名认真研究时间旅行的人走出了衣橱。
When that came out, I remember turning on my email-- I was used to getting a couple of emails every day-- I remember turning it on one day and it was lit up. I mean, it was like hundreds of emails from all over the world. And I started getting interviews from everywhere asking about this new work that I was doing. Even though other people were accepting of it-- and I have to say, it's even now I feel like, you know, they really aren't carting me away. [LAUGHING]
当那个出来时，我记得打开我的电子邮件——我习惯于每天收到几封电子邮件——我记得有一天打开它，它亮了起来。我的意思是，就像来自世界各地的数百封电子邮件。我开始从各地接到采访，询问我正在做的这项新工作。尽管其他人接受它——我必须说，即使现在我觉得，你知道，他们真的没有把我关起来。[笑]
Finally, he presented his work before other physicists at the Third International Association for Relativistic Dynamics Conference in Washington, DC. In the audience was Bryce DeWitt, a contemporary of Einstein's and a physics giant, who had helped pioneer a new approach to quantum mechanics. After his presentation, Ron told the physicist about his father and why he was so interested in time travel.
最后，他在华盛顿特区举行的第三届国际相对论动力学会议上向其他物理学家展示了他的工作。听众中有布莱斯·德维特，爱因斯坦的当代人，一位物理学泰斗，他帮助开创了一种量子力学的新方法。演讲结束后，罗恩告诉这位物理学家关于他父亲的事以及为什么他对时间旅行如此感兴趣。
What I didn't expect-- DeWitt asked a technical question with some of the other people, but then when the question and answer period was over, he actually said, to the whole audience, he said, well, "I don't know whether you'll ever see your father again, but he would have been proud of you." And I have to tell you,--
我没预料到的是——德维特和其他人问了一个技术问题，但在问答环节结束后，他实际上对全体听众说，好吧，“我不知道你是否会再见到你的父亲，但他会为你感到骄傲的。”我必须告诉你——
Is that not something you had thought of before?
这不是你之前想过的事情吗？
I wouldn't have thought of it just in that way. But you know, I would have. But it's one thing when you think about, well, you know, I'm proud of what I've done, or my father might be proud of-- it's a whole different thing when it's someone totally independent of you. DeWitt's statement was a validation to me of my life, because here was this great man saying, "your father would be proud of you." I mean, it was like, to me, it couldn't get better than that.
我不会只是那样想的。但你知道，我会的。但当你想到时是一回事，好吧，你知道，我为我所做的感到骄傲，或者我的父亲可能为——当它是完全独立于你的人时，那是完全不同的事情。德维特的话是对我生命的验证，因为这里有这位伟人说，“你的父亲会为你感到骄傲。”我的意思是，对我来说，没有比这更好的了。
But something else happened at the conference, too. DeWitt had said this other thing, that he didn't know if Ron would ever see his father again. And Ron started to puzzle over that, over why DeWitt would say that. And then he sort of sheepishly realized something he'd never taken a moment to think through, which is that his time machine would never work, at least not the way he wanted it to. Maybe he'd be able to stir up time inside the machine, but if Ron followed his own equations to their logical conclusion, the furthest he'd ever be able to go back is the moment the machine was first switched on. So he wouldn't be able to return to the 1950s to save his father.
但会议上也发生了别的事情。德维特说了另一件事，他不知道罗恩是否会再见到他的父亲。罗恩开始琢磨那个问题，为什么德维特会那样说。然后他有点羞愧地意识到了他从未花时间仔细思考过的事情，那就是他的时间机器永远不会工作，至少不会像他想要的那样工作。也许他能够在他机器内搅动时间，但如果罗恩遵循他自己的方程得出逻辑结论，他所能回到最远的时间就是机器第一次被开启的那一刻。所以他无法回到50年代去拯救他的父亲。
Weirdly, Ron says he wasn't devastated when he realized that. For most of his life, he'd held on to this plan he invented as an 11-year-old. He turned himself into a scientist, sacrificed his marriage, and worked in secret for decades. And finally, in his 50s, without him ever really noticing, the plan he made as a boy got replaced with a more adult plan, one based on an adult's understanding of what was actually possible. So by the time he found out he'd never see his father again, he didn't need to.
奇怪的是，罗恩说当他意识到这一点时并没有崩溃。在他生命的大部分时间里，他都坚持这个他11岁时发明的计划。他把自己变成了一名科学家，牺牲了他的婚姻，并在秘密中工作了几十年。最后，在他50多岁时，在他从未真正注意到的情况下，他儿时制定的计划被一个更成人的计划所取代，一个基于成年人对什么是真正可能的理解的计划。所以当他发现他永远不会再见到他父亲时，他不需要了。
Josh Gleason in Portland, Maine. Ron Mallett has a memoir about his dad and his research called Time Traveler.
乔什·格里森在缅因州波特兰。罗恩·马利特有一本关于他爸爸和研究的回忆录，书名叫《时间旅行者》。
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Emily Youssef. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好吧，我们的节目今天由萨拉·柯尼格和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨运行我们的网站。生产帮助来自塞斯·林德和艾米丽·尤塞夫。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains how he hooked up with his best friend Urkel.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他解释了他如何与他最好的朋友厄克尔联系上的。
I wasn't in that income group where I would have been able to run with the white nerds.
我不在那个收入阶层，我无法和那里的白人书呆子混在一起。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。